although Call of Duty war zone 2
introduces the new al-mazra map it
integrates both new and iconic locations
together to serve as a crucible for the
battle royale's big overhaul to a lot of
the core features and the introduction
of Modern Warfare 2's mechanics and
movement the end result is mixed with
some of the new additions making the
moment-to-moment action feel fresh while
updates to other classic war zone
features feel like a step back for the
Battle Royale title
Warzone 2's 150 player skirmishes of
solo duo trio and quad combatants are
played out on the new al-mazra map the
fictional desert region in Western Asia
does a great job of combining new Modern
Warfare to multiplayer maps with several
nostalgic locations that long time Call
of Duty fans will recognize in every
location old or new Blends together to
create a vibrant and beautiful
environment in comparison to Modern
warfares for dance map almazra feels
more diverse with its mixture of arid
desert large bodies of water tight
cities and exposed small towns
water was very limited in the original
war zone because Modern Warfare lacked
swimming mechanics but the sequel brings
over all the features and mechanics of
Modern Warfare 2 which means that large
bodies of water boats and swimming are
now added to the mix and their
meaningful additions that give you fresh
ways to take on fights in war zone 2.
being able to dive away from a bad
gunfight or use it for stealth to flank
an opponent in particular adds a new
kind of dynamism to engagements there's
also a much better balance with how the
map is designed although vast for dance
stadium and caldera's Peak weighted the
focus to those massive landmarks making
them choke points of sorts al-mazura
however doesn't have a similar focal
point that's hard to Traverse around
like the aforementioned locations
instead there's a great mix of
environments with buildings for Close
Quarters action but also a lot of open
sight lines for sniping thankfully these
spacious areas don't leave you too
vulnerable when passing through them as
there are plenty of large rocks and
other things to use this cover so
rotating from point to point doesn't
always feel like a straw struggle one of
the major gameplay changes Warzone 2
introduces is a brand new Circle
mechanic instead of one large Circle
there are multiple micro circles
appearing at once there can be up to
three of these smaller circles active in
any given match but eventually these all
merge back together for the final Circle
although unconventional for the Battle
Royale genre this approach does add a
bit more spice to the mid-game action of
War Zone matches on verdansk or Caldera
matches would quickly turn into players
camping to wait out further Circle
collapses almazara's micro circles Force
players together into condensed
locations earlier to offer you more
engagements leading up to the final
Circle collapse this simple change
ensures matches feel engaging and like
something is always happening around
again good work while micro circles are
a smart and welcome change the same
can't be said of War Zone 2's revamped
Gulag sadly almazura comes with an
overly complex and much larger Gulag
Arena which often puts your fate in
someone else's hands the gulag is no
longer a simple 1v1 Arena and instead
your first death will transport you to a
multi-level Arena where you fight in 2v2
matches while temporarily paired up with
another random player the original Gulag
was an exciting way to give you a second
chance provided you added skills to win
the 1v1 fight but this new 2v2 twist
leaves your fate partially in a random
player's hands although this Gulag does
utilize the game's proximity chat
feature someone like me who sits in
party chats with friends or Squad mates
will find themselves struggling to
communicate with a temporary Duo partner
and if they or you die the odds of
survival become much more Grim for the
surviving player
al-mazra also features the addition of
the new stronghold and black site loot
locations at the end of the first Circle
collapse strongholds are activated on
the map and there are 77 random
locations that the strongholds can
appear however there will only ever be
three on the map at once strongholds are
marked on the map as a large Castle icon
and the first team to reach one must
defuse a bomb there before a timer
expires otherwise the objective for the
remaining strongholds is to clear out a
specific number of enemies completing
these will reward you with items like
your Loadout killstreaks gas masks and
such you can go for an even greater
challenge with black sites which are
basically just an even more dangerous
form of strongholds a black side is
marked on the map with a skull icon and
contains considerably tougher armored
enemies including a juggernaut boss it's
also an enticing place to conquer for
the in-game loot you receive for use in
the match itself which means it can turn
this location into a major PowerPoint
with all the high-end Loot and Intel it
offers looting feels more natural to the
environment in war zone 2. cash can be
looted from registers while house
supplies are found in places like first
aid kits and bathrooms and ambulances
it's much easier to find the item that
you need because you can look in
specific places that make sense instead
of relying on the randomness of Supply
crates Warzone also adds a simplified
backpack system that feels like a hybrid
of Black Ops 4's blackout Battle Royale
and the original war zone you can start
with a small pack that has six inventory
slots but you can loot or purchase a
pack that has more at first having a
backpack to Stow and pull items from
seems like a hassle because you can
often find yourself hiding somewhere
rummaging through your pack to drop or
add items feeling vulnerable in the
process however it's actually really
convenient to be able to carry more
supplies it's nice to know you can lug
around an extra stack of armor plates
for yourself or that one teammate who
never loots well enough Arma pouch
marked however this approach does pave
the way for some potentially annoying
situations too such as having a backpack
full of one item there are opportunities
to spam certain items if you're able to
collect enough of them and this this
could have a negative impact in late
game scenarios
[Music]
just like blackout there is now a rare
three-tier armor item by default you'll
only be able to carry two armor plates
and will now need to loot a three plate
vest to equip a third one this is a bit
disappointing because the original war
zone steered away from having the rarity
levels of armor to keep everyone in
equal playing field with the option for
anyone to have three plates at any given
time now whether or not you can have
three plates depends on your luck of
looting or purchasing the three-tier
upgrade at a buy station Loadout drops
return for war zone 2 and they can still
drop at any time between the second and
sixth Circle collapses but they are no
longer specifically reserved for a
specific player or Squad anyone can grab
any Loadout drop that hits the map on
the one hand you can no longer see your
specific Loadout and gauge how many
enemies map in the area as before if
your Loadout drop was stacked near three
or four others you're in Greater danger
than if your Loadout dropped alone on
the other hand I think it's more
important to have the freedom to pick
and choose what drop you want to grab
especially when your specific Loadout
could drop in a location that wouldn't
be safe or reachable warzone's stations
now have their own unique collection of
items to purchase as opposed to every
station having the exact same items you
can even buy your custom primary weapon
at a buy station and while the purchases
don't include a full Loadout with a
secondary weapon lethals and perks it's
nice to be able to at least get one
reliable weapon in your hands it's great
having a bigger selection of items to
purchase with more lethal and tactical
items but be careful of your Reliance on
these items as there is a limited
quantity of items that can be bought at
each station that means someone could
come along with tons of cash and buy all
the uavs it's also worth noting that
vehicle play is better than ever in
Warzone thanks to the addition of Modern
Warfare 2's maneuverability options it's
so easy to Squad up and hang on the
sides of vehicles for a quick ride
although you'll need to refuel to keep
using those Vehicles overall vehicle
combat feels less daunting and more
exciting and situational here with these
new ways to counter them finally Warzone
2 also pairs Modern Warfare 2's movement
with the same fast time to kill in
multiplayer I really enjoyed the dial
back and classic feel to the movement
this year but the quick time to kill
means there's considerably less time to
react to situations it's so easy to peek
your head out of a building or come
around a corner and get deleted by an
enemy
warzone's gunfights often felt best
after the health cap or armor was
slightly raised to give players more of
a Fighting Chance when there could be a
push and pull between combatants
thankfully most of my complaints about
war zone 2 are things that could easily
be adjusted in future updates almazura
comes out the gate as a balanced and
diversified map that feels like a huge
step up from Caldera and dare I say it
even from verdansk with the Fresh Circle
mechanics and strongholds being paired
with the solid Gunplay mechanics and
movement from Modern Warfare 2. this
could be a really great year for warzone
all Targets eliminated
another major addition to Warzone 2 is
DMZ mode which puts Call of Duty style
spin on the extraction shooter genre
this mode has a max of 66 players in
trios on warzone's Al mazura map where
they're tasked with fighting looting and
extracting there are objectives you can
complete for XP and cash but ultimately
the fun of DMZ is getting to choose how
you want to play you can load into a
match with the intent of looting cash
and weapons playing aggressively and
seeking out gunfights or you can try to
complete specific objectives for extra
XP and rewards while DMZ doesn't have
the overall tactical feel of other
extraction Shooters like escape from
tarkov and Hunt Showdown it still has
the Thrills of a high risk High reward
game mode you can keep all the weapons
in loot earned for a successful
extraction while also losing everything
if you die before extracting you're also
limited to how many items you can carry
so it can quickly become a game of
deciding what items to keep in your
backpack and what loot should be left
behind before extract thing DMZ utilizes
many features and mechanics from Warzone
2 including the new stronghold locations
buy stations Ai and more AI enemies are
found all throughout the map but they
feel more appropriate here in this
objective style mode than they do in
Battle Royale they're a recruit easy
level AIS that can be found scattered
around in buildings in various locations
but the AI opponents at strongholds or
objective areas are often armored and
much more challenging to fight for the
high tier loot I don't think a battle
royale needs AI outside of locations
like strongholds but it really works
well for DMZ as the various levels of
bots keep you engaged in the action from
move active to objective and they fill
out the world a bit more the buy
stations generally look and work the
same as they do in Warzone 2 but in DMZ
you can sell items you scavenge for
extra cash but the only complaint here
being the buy station's new interface
DMZ also utilizes warzone's new
stronghold feature but this one is a bit
different than the Battle Royale version
as these require locating key cards to
fit the questing nature of DMZ While
most of dmz's features and mechanics are
from Warzone one convenient addition
that's exclusive to DMZ is an easier way
to get your squad mates back into the
fight you can revive eliminated Squad
mates at their death location at any
time in the match meaning there are no
trips to a buy station to purchase their
return dead teammates are marked as a
blue Health icon and there is no time
limit or any additional steps needed to
return teammates to a match DMZ also
allows players to complete contracts
faction missions and random activities
that can happen throughout the match
contracts are given by one of three
factions in DMZ Legion White Lotus or
black mouse these faction missions have
increasing levels of difficulty and a
wide variety so while a huge grind to
complete them all they're very rewarding
and assure you always have plenty to do
regardless of whether you choose to
complete faction missions or you have
another goal plan for your time in DMZ
there will be random occurrences and
activities happening during the match
and some of the modes charms comes from
these for example you can use drills to
open safes and score tons of cash for
useful items like uavs but it comes at
the risk of making a ton of noise and
alerting nearby enemies or you can
trigger a Sam turret which will shoot
down a plane carrying a supply drop but
again it's at the cost of enemies
hearing the action and wanting to fight
you for the loot activities like these
seem simple but they can quickly turn
dicey
DMZ is definitely an interesting and
enjoyable sandbox mode and it gives you
more ways to play unlock guns and level
up with XP Activision never marketed
this as a Call of Duty take on escape
from tarkov or any other extraction game
but those comparisons were quickly drawn
by the community however you don't want
to go into this mode with that
expectation as it doesn't quite have the
same grittiness and tactical feel as
those other games DMZ plays more like an
objective-based Warzone LTM with the
option to excel at any time the overall
success of this mode depends on what
future updates bring as is the world
feels alive and objectives are mostly
fun to complete but I can see DMZ
getting old unless we see seasonal
updates that add new missions features
special events and other layers to the
experience and keep DMZ feeling fresh
this is definitely a mode that leaves
tons of room for expansion my time with
both Battle Royale and DMZ was played on
PlayStation 5 and this was a much
smoother launch than I expected with
modern warfare 2s crashing and freezing
however other players have reported
experiencing crashes freezes and
stuttering issues Warzone 2 comes out
Swinging with the strongest map yet as
al-mazra's design is both visually
appealing and well balanced to encourage
more moment-to-moment action in player
movement the sequel tosses in enough new
features and changes to make gameplay
feel fresh and give a dramatic change to
the game's Pace to set Warzone 2 apart
from the original and the Battle Royale
matches are still a blast despite the
setbacks to Classic features packaged
with DMZ which feels like a Sandbox hit
free-to-play Call of Duty players have
so many more ways to jump into the
action and level up this year
[Music]